después de 38 días en el cargo del
ministro de finanzas cuasi cuarta en ha
dado finalmente un paso al costado ha
renunciado a su cargo luego de
diferentes voces y sectores pidieran su
renuncia por la crisis histórica que ha
vivido este país luego de que el
gobierno presentará lo que se conoce
como el mini presupuesto este hecho
Tiene efectos políticos enormes la
primera ministra Lis tras que también
lleva 38 días en el cargo Está tratando
de sobrevivir después de la crisis
enorme en la economía y la caída de la
libra esterlina y también la falta de
credibilidad que tienen los mercados en
el gobierno británico está sacrificando
a uno de sus grandes aliados para poder
seguir en el cargo casi cuartel tuvo que
sufrir además la vergüenza pública de
ser regresado de una reunión de expertos
en economía del fondo monetario
internacional en Washington para
regresar esta mañana
su renuncia en la carta de división ha
dicho que el gobierno debe seguir con
esos compromisos de la disciplina fiscal
Y por supuesto veremos más adelante
cuando son los resultados y los efectos
de esta renuncia en los mercados